that didn't Caroline this morning you've
talked about the ways in which ITV
talked to Mr X
um about the situation ITV and I've
written down you've you've called it um
a review twice I think and an
investigation
once I've never caught it in an
investigation I actually said I heard
you say that but then you use the word I
might have said investigated because I
think what we do is we did investigate
but I I wouldn't call it an
investigation because that gives it a
kind of formality and and and structure
that because of the rumors and because
of the time period it didn't have okay I
I've spoken to someone who's who's
friendly with Mr X
um who says that
he felt that the uh review uh the
investigations that took place
um made it quite difficult for him to
talk and he was under a lot of pressure
not to talk um he quotes one particular
conversation with a manager and
um the words used were is everything
okay between you and Philip
those were the words used and he didn't
I'm told feel that he could really
answer that with any candor
uh because well for all the reasons that
we understand
um he also I'm told feels that uh he
left the program and didn't want to now
I've heard a number of different people
describe his move to loose women as a
promotion that he applied for
can you confirm that of his own volition
he applied for this job and that his job
there was a promotion okay can I I'll
just go back to some of the things
you've just
um just you've just outlined
um difficult to talk was it was under
pressure not to talk so we'd need to
understand from whom because in every
conversation he's had with the head of
production he has actually not only felt
less pressure when talking to her
because she has been so supportive and
helpful of her didn't want him to reveal
to anybody the relationship but but
that's a very different issue that's a
very different matter saying Philip
didn't want him and I don't know the
right I don't know whether that's true
or not I don't know because I will I I
don't have that information but if
Philip was putting him under pressure
ITV we're not putting them under
pressure on anything we were actually
asking he was coming to us for uh
counseling and for other things and we
were helping him to be able to talk
freely to us without anybody else in the
organization or even knowing about it so
I wanted to apply for a job at loose
woman I come on to that but I want to be
very clear that it's Philip that was
putting him under pressure and not ITV
that was putting him under pressure
because they were two quite separate
things and it's very important we stick
to facts here and at the fat of the
loose women issue is that he absolutely
applied for that job and he got it and
it was a promotion but if we just
tracked back he actually applied for a
job on this morning as a researcher and
Kyla will give you the dates before he
applied for loose women and he didn't
get the job on this morning he went
through a recruitment process he didn't
get the job he then applied for a job on
loose women with 29 other applicants in
the process and he got the job and I
think we have to remember
we're talking about person X it's very
hard to know he was extremely capable
very confident young person he really
was and he was he he impressed people he
came across so he was ambitious you've
said that about his ambition before and
I take that point anyway I'm just
relating to you that his friend has
taught me that he didn't actually want
to to leave and indeed that somebody was
somebody was removed from uh loose women
there is no evidence for us we have
looked at the process we have looked at
the procedure we have looked at the line
manager who interviewed him and we have
looked at the other applicants so right
I mean we have looked into this in in
real detail because we're aware of the
the allegations that there are out there
um and our HR teams have absolutely
confirmed as Carolyn has outlined this
was in
2019 to get my day to write 29 team that
he applied for a transfer he was looking
for a promotion my understanding it's
not I mean Kevin is obviously much
closer to uh the world of production and
Runners but people don't become a runner
to be a runner for life you're a runner
and you look fine I understand that this
was a promotion production secretary is
a promotion you don't mind let's where's
on a wee bit because we've allowed to
get through my uh I've spoken to a
number of different people at the
program Uh current and former employees
they say it was a bit of an Open Secret
what was going on between him and Philip
Schofield people knew about it you know
the Show reel that the chair described
obviously isn't a normal thing uh to to
happen uh we we know that I worked in TV
most rare for a runner to be afforded
that kind of time and privileged access
um did when he was hired did anybody
find out
um what his history was with Philip
Schofield did he check when Philip
Schofield first met him which is you
know was when he was very young did
anybody discovered the Phillips
Schofield had followed him on social
media but he was very young to anybody
look into that or notice that or is that
all been a surprise to you
why don't why don't I take that
um no no one looked into no one looked
into the detail at the time as I say
this was an individual one of 50 to 60
work placements on daytime
when he he came for one half weeks work
experience noting that Philip Schofield
was a family friend there were no alarm
Bells there was nothing to see in that
we will have many
um similar applications for work
experience where someone lists family
friend across ITV so no no one looked
back and we wouldn't do that Mr
Nicholson for any uh work experience
person we wouldn't look into background
we would either give them work
experience or we wouldn't be able to
give them work experience because we
couldn't do it and so it was 19 and
fully supervised
at the moment because price reports are
that Philip Schofield is paying for the
lawyer my understanding is that Philip
Schofield is paying for it I think
Philip mendot in the BB
Q standing that's not true his his
lawyers are working at pro bono because
they're concerned about some of the
issues in the case
um
but you've been in touch with him
recently
for snacks yes Phillip schofields no
personags yes
um can I just check how many people
approach Senior Management with concerns
about presenters editors or the culture
at this morning uh Can I Turn to You Mr
laiko about this
came to me directly with complaining
about behaviors or something
um I don't think any that I can recall
honestly
well that's funny because I have a copy
of an email
and it says I understand it it's from
ITV referring to you in our meeting the
Monday the 4th of October 2021 uh you
referred to your concerns about the
conduct of Phillip Schofield and another
colleague working on this morning I'm
not able to share all the details uh but
I can find no evidence to suggest that
Kevin likel failed to take action on the
allegations that you have raised with
them
um it's not a question if I'm not being
interested in the concerns he is
interested in the concerns and he does
take the allegations that you have
raised seriously there's an example of
somebody who did contact you contact who
it is without permission okay well this
is an email from ITV so if someone had
to ask you to me somebody's senior at
ITV to the person who made the complaint
I know someone from your your from you
for you to the complainant yeah
I really need to see that I need to
check that so
okay
um because that seems quite significant
um
we've talked about non-disclosure
agreements a number of times today and
you've confirmed that Mr X has not been
asked to sign a non-disclosure agreement
though he was given a payoff wasn't he
I wouldn't I wouldn't characterize it as
a payoff his role was made redundant
um and and he stopped after lockdown he
was a fixed term contractor so staff we
treat them in exactly the same way he'd
been on fixed term contracts for
throughout his time is that normal to
give pills to Poker non-staff it's
absolutely standard
precise I have spoken to our chief
people officer who has confirmed that
his
settlement agreement that he entered
into was completely standard there is a
very clear carve out for whistleblowing
speaking up and the payment I understand
was absolutely standard formulaic as we
would have paid to anyone else at that
it was a redundancy it was a redundant
his role was redundant post-covered okay
um
yesterday the BBC said to us that they
were going to release people from
non-disclosure agreements that they'd
signed in the past unless it was
specifically to do with commercial
confidentiality
are ITV prepared to do the same
I think we have any well to the extent I
mean to the extent that there are
non-disclosure agreements that were
entered into historically I don't know
what where those would be or what period
of time
um
then yes I mean we don't we have no at
the moment I would have no knowledge of
an NDA other than for commercial matters
um so other than commercial matters
I don't have any not I have no knowledge
that we have signed ndas if if we have
anything historically that we don't know
about we will look into that but we
would have no reason I think to sign
ndas were you saying something a bit
more cautious than Miss Mullins because
Miss Mullins a second ago said yes
people would be released from those and
you're saying that you'd look into it is
it look into or release no really both
I mean we need to find out if there are
any right but I've raised my question
carefully we're not talking about
commercial uh ndes with commercial
sensitivity
um just NDS that for example might refer
to pay offs through bullying or other
matters like that well can I say we
will say that they couldn't speak up
about bullying or harassment or sexual
uh harassment or anything like that we
we that there is kylo already referred
to this there is a carve out that is is
quite clear in any agreement that a
standard agreement that we would do good
and just to go back to my previous
question Mr Lego I'll ask for permission
to send you uh that that email but just
for the record you're saying that to the
best of your recollection you had no
meetings with anybody where they talked
about uh bullying culture or
inappropriate behavior with regard to
Phillip Schofield yeah I'm I'm pretty
certain I would I would remember if they
were talking about well out of thoughts
um I just asked one final question can
you confirm the daytime production staff
at this morning refer to Their audience
in production meetings as tar block
traces
is what sorry Tower block traces I've
never heard that first I've never heard
that
number of people have told me that I've
never heard that I don't even truly
dismiss it if an idea is regarded as too
highbrow well um I've told people say
would that really appeal to the terrible
traces
I I agreed never heard that it's a
horrible thing I I
yeah horrible thing to say it's it's not
what ITV would be looking at as a target
audience right we wouldn't describe our
talk audience in that way and I know
that I do know one thing which is that
the daytime team on every show really
cares about the audience so that
surprises me